Hey everybody, this
is Wesley Chun,
engineer and developer
advocate here at Google.
The question of
the day is, are you
a developer looking
to get your feet wet
integrating Google technologies
into your startup or enterprise
apps.
Well, Startup
Launch is a program
that provides startups in
all stages with the platform,
resources, online content,
mentorship, and training
to help you start
something around your idea,
build that product, and
grow your user base.
Launchpad is a one-week program
for early stage startups
focused on subjects including
UI design, product strategy,
marketing, and
business development.
But not everyone can make
it to Launchpad events,
so here we are.
Launchpad Online
represents video content
for startups, hobbyists,
and even enterprises
to help you learn the
skills you need to succeed.
Since technology is generally
at the heart of your solution,
we will put one primary focus
on Google developer tools
and APIs.
What are those?
Well, over the last
few years, we've
created web and
mobile apps that you
may have used, like search,
YouTube, or one or more Google
Apps like Gmail or Google Docs.
However, while my colleagues
are quite happy producing tools
like those for everyone,
we can't possibly
create them as quickly as all
of you out there combined.
No, seriously, it's true.
So we did the next best thing.
We've made some of
our technologies
available for you to use,
including the developer tools
and APIs you see here.
And we're adding new
features and APIs regularly.
What can you do with them?
You can help your
users find out where
they need to go with Google Maps
while they're using your app
to find places to
go, eat, and play.
You can give your
users the ability
to edit text or graphical
files on their Google Drive.
Or perhaps, you want
to allow your users
to take videos from
their smartphones
and automatically upload
them so they could easily
share with friends or family,
without the phone or camera
to computer to YouTube
to email process.
Oh, by the way, you can use
multiple APIs in the same app,
like uploading those videos
to YouTube and Google Drive.
These are just a
few ideas of what
you can do-- create an app,
without reinventing wheels,
whether it be for mobile, the
web, or, very likely, both.
But how does one get
started using Google APIs?
Some developers have told
us that it's not always
easy to learn our
APIs or that there
isn't enough documentation
or working samples.
In addition to covering skills
like design and distribution,
I'm happy to be your host for
the Launchpad Online video
series for developers
that aims to address
those exact problems.
Each episode describes
and demonstrates
how to use one specific Google
API feature or developer
tool, allowing you to
get up to speed quickly.
Oh, one more thing-- while this
series is beginner friendly,
we do expect you
to be a developer,
meaning you've
coded in languages
like JavaScript or Python.
If you're new to
programming, there
are many MOOCs-- or massive
open online courses--
and tutorials out there
to help you learn to code.
Once you've got some
experience under your belt,
we'll be here to help
you launch your idea.
Now it's up to you.
Start exploring our APIs is on
the Google Developers home page
or see other videos
in this series using
the link shown on this page.
This is Wesley Chun,
and I look forward
to having you join
me on this adventure,
learning and leveraging
Google technologies
available through our
APIs and developer tools.
We'll see you soon on
the Launchpad Online
or at a Launchpad event.